we have 100 minecraft players with
leather armor and stone swords
and they're going to chase us all
throughout this map through a castle
into a boat into a mythical wonderland
it's going to be insane
but if they catch up to us and kill us
before 15 minutes is up i'm deleting the
channel no
as long as one of us survives we're good
do not die keep running
defend the forts and server drop
the blast all right and boom
oh gosh they're going they're going oh
we doing it right now we're doing it
right now
it's happening i'm going to shoot some
of them all right fend them off
oh taylor you got in the way a server
use the secret weapon
weapon okay good oh my gosh they're
still there they don't know they're
trying to attack us
the doors of the castle have been rigged
to take like a few thousand damage so as
of right now no one else is allowed in
besides us
carl chandler breach i'm fighting i'm
fighting it's only been half a minute we
cannot
die or i literally have to delete the
channel oh hey dream hey dream hi
oh hey dream we need to defend the
castle oh yeah sorry dream is our castle
defender our trap returned to normal all
right guys we gotta kill them please
holy cow dream can you can you go down
there and just you know
do the thing i will go down wait the
gates are taking a lot of damage the
gates are going to break open soon
should we drop the anvils drop the
anvils yes drop them drop them
[Music]
dreams going in dreams going in
[Music]
chandler don't die fine actually you
know what let's use strategy i'm getting
lava buckets
uh oh i'm in the corner i'm dead if
chandler dies that's okay
we all have to die to delete the channel
that's true wait but chandler please
don't die
i'm dead i'm dead chandler run away i'm
in the corner
shitler died trailer i forgot this is
wood and i put lava on it chandler you
can still help us
come back to the castle oh no we lost
our best player
dude the front doors are about to break
all right jump on the slime pads down
here boys
they're not even going after me oh god
it's open isn't it
oh okay no the anvils are there oh that
scared the crap out of me i'm getting
beat up when they finally break through
the front
gates we gotta run to the ship remember
boys we cannot afford to die
dream you can take a break from fending
the gates there are
hundreds of people just running all the
doors broke guys get to the ship
carl i swear to god if you don't get to
these ships we're leaving you no
all right we're coming to the ships all
right they're getting through
carl where are you i'm right next to you
yeah
all right dream dream dream dream dream
all right wait wait for it
all right flick the switch someone
someone has to flick it
[Music]
oh no you gotta blast me
no wait wait someone man the ladders oh
they're all around the boat
they're following me oh shoot guys
abandon ship
abandon ship go to the next place dream
keep them off us they're coming
carl chris why do you have to stay alive
there's so much cobwebs who did this
i don't know where to go but we cannot
die we were supposed to run away
guys i'm not gonna lie it's not looking
good i can't run
ten and a half minutes guys guys guys
what is going on
oh there's lava i'm surrounded by people
and there's lava
holy cow i had half a heart there's two
blood
oh no no you guys missed the lever i
died so now it's chris and coral left
chris and carl haven't died yet we got
to keep them alive they're just running
past me i'm hiding at this point screw
this
wait they don't notice they don't notice
you guys have to stay alive for 10 more
minutes
ah they figured it out
keep them alive i'm hiding screw this
you guys can run right past me
chris have you died yet no i died i died
i didn't see the guy oh you're our last
hope i'm right i'm running next i'm
running up i'll protect you carl
you protect me all right but remember if
you kill someone
they have to go all the way back to
spawn so oh my gosh look they took over
our four
look at him up there they're just
looking down on us all right let's
protect the president with carl
oh wait why did somebody pour lava on me
what the crap they grabbed the lava from
the chest
okay i'm dropping lava around me screw
this
they're bullying us jimmy we don't want
to delete the channel
we need to set up they're going to come
back i'm dropping lava guys i feel like
we should go
into the castle here i think carl should
just hide down here
oh my gosh there's more players guys
guys guys protect carl
let's spend off the people coming in
then let's overtake the castle i'm
behind you guys i got the rump i got the
rump
ow ow i'm about to die they're not one
hit killing
they're not one hit killing carl you're
good you good carl yeah
i'm just scared i don't want to delete
the channel carl our future is in your
hands
carl it's all gonna be your fault if we
have to delete the channel
oh i stepped in lava i will put my life
on the line thank you dream
no i'm melting help wait does dream also
count for our channel like if he dies
no just us all right there seems to be a
gap in people guys let's go storm the
castle so we have a protection all right
let's go
all right there's people up top we need
to take it over take them out baby
take them out to dinner get the guy on
the throne this is our guy
get out of here there's people coming
from behind guys get away
why are you here come on get out of our
castle
do you hate this channel do you not want
to win money in the future
is that what you want if you guys delete
this channel church who's gonna need a
job
carl has to stay alive for five more
minutes oh yeah baby let's go
there's a person in this in the trunk in
the throat
get up all right i'm next to you dream
i'm next to you you can have most of
them there's a few people up top i'm
gonna take care of them that way we
don't have any surprises
oh oh oh i'm terrified if i fall i'm
screwed all right
oh yeah and i got knocked uh uh i don't
know what to do
yeah i like being the president that you
guys protect because i don't like
killing people
no i died oh
getting killed bull jedi he wants me to
not ever win money here
all right here i'm gonna lava off one
entrance oh i found a guy hiding there's
a guy also in the throne
kill him dream i want you to be glued to
carl do not leave his side
dream i'm on the throne okay kristen
chandler come up here it's fine
oh yeah i got him i got him the next
wave will be here soon guys if they
breach the castle
they could kill carl if they kill carl
the channel gets deleted
wait there's people behind you oh guys
defend
the fort don't let carl die i'm really
bad at dying don't worry dream
i'm not good at pvp jimmy i'm not either
oh wait i forgot it doesn't matter if i
die
i fell in the lava i fell in the lava oh
oh someone hit me in lava
someone hit me in lava hey i lava
they're storming
all right i found a bucket of lava up
the ladder flutter all right i trust in
your dream
one and a half minutes remaining please
don't let them die boys i'm blocking the
middle gate so they have to go around
the side carl what does it look like up
there
it's actually kind of peaceful i'm just
gonna hang out well there's a lot of
people in the castle now
ah they're storming carl stay on this
side stay on the side i love how dream
knows what he's doing and we're just
like herded her
i found this guy hiding over here carl
if you die in this next minute i will
never forgive you will you like me more
if i don't
yes i've got a bunch of kills we're our
defense is working they're going for
carl
they're going for him 30 seconds carl do
not die
what if i just killed carl in the last
30 seconds oh
right side dream at this point don't let
even chris or chandler up there kill
anything in sight stop
oh i was joking i was joking and there
we go
we survived 15 minutes without dying i'm
gonna join the discord and tell them
whoever kills you on the throne first
wins a thousand dollars i died chandler
died chris died but carl never died
we do not have to delete the gaming
channel yay now i don't have to be
homeless
carl i think you should sit on the
throne okay can i let them gobble me up
now
whoever kills cole first
wins 1 000 i'm not gonna move again okay
guys whoever kills me kills me
stop punching me guys guys
carl did you die i'm about to i'm about
to die oh where did he come from
dude they're jumping from the ceiling on
you carl
they are smart i just literally saw a
guy just rappel down on carl's face
dude the minecraft kids are smart
resourceful too
we just released 100 more players i'm
gonna go see if i can find them you guys
stay there and defend carl
oh boy there's a lot of people i'm gonna
start running
guys where'd you guys go dream you tell
us what to do boom
and then retreat as soon as they get
they reach the line
okay taylor can you for the love of god
stop shooting me with an arrow dream you
hit me in the lava
i didn't touch you all right oh
sorry dream on your right girl get out
of here get out of here kids
get out of here there's so many people i
don't know what to do
oh if only my arrows weren't lagging if
i hit you dream i'm sorry
you're on top of me also my nose itches
but i'm in a battle
ah i'm trying to take some take some
damage for you all right i died
they're above me i'm about to die oh
my god no god i'm taking all the damage
it actually worked it worked for real
i'm taking it
i said that oh i died me and chris are
dead
i'm sweating carl move
they think it's me oh god
no oh
carl no who did it who did it ox knew
ox new congratulations on killing carl
oh my god
why would you do that to me oxnard if
you would have killed carl 10 minutes
earlier i would have had to delete this
channel
seriously yeah so thank goodness you
waited you won
a thousand dollars though
congratulations i i don't know how to
feel right now
and thank you for watching this video
subscribe